القياديه بين كوباني شكرا على قبولك
الحديث معنا
مرحبا بكم
قمتم بالكثير من العمليات التنظيم داعش
اخرها كانت عمليه صاعقه الجزيره
هل لديكم حصيله لمجمل هذه العمليات
والعمليه الاخيره تحديدا عدد القيتم القبض
عليهم
تابعا يعني النهار عملياتنا العسكريه
انطلقت بسبب الاوضاع الامنيه في المنطقه
ولم تبدا فجاه في اغسطس الماضي بدانا
عمليه متاخره في مخيم الهول وكانت
التهديدات الامنيه تتزايد في تلك المنطقه
سبب تاجيل تلك العمليه هو محاوله داعش
الهروب من سجن الصناعه في الحسكه بعد ذلك
تزايدت هجمات الدوله التركيه على مناطقنا
ومع ذلك تم تنفيذ عمليه الانسانيه والامن
واستمرت لمده الشهر ورصدنا عددا من
الخلايا النائمه لداعش بالاضافه الى ذلك
تم تحديد واغلاق مواقع داعش التي يدربون
فيها الاطفال كما اغلقنا مواقع كانوا
يعذبون فيها بعض سكان المخيم بدا التنظيم
داعش بحفر العديد من الانفاق في المخيم
وكان عناصره يعصبون اعين من يتم اختطافهم
ويبقونهم في الانفاق كان عناصر داعش
يخطفون الناس من داخل المخيم وخارجه
ويعذبونهم وجمعوا عددا كبيرا من الاسلحه
وادوات التعذيب العمليه التي نفذناها كانت
ناجحه
واعتقلت كبار
اعترفوا بافعالهم داخل وخارج المخيمات
وتمت مشاركه مقاطع الفيديو مع وسائل
الاعلام ايضا
قللنا من التهديدات في مخيم الهول لكن لا
تزال هناك تهديدات امنيه
80% من سكان مخيم الهول هم زوجات واطفال
عناصر داعش هناك اشخاص من 56 جنسيه مختلفه
في مخيم الهول قتل ازواجهن وابائهم في
القتال او انهم موجودون حاليا في سجون في
شمال وشرق سوريا
غيرنا اساليب عملياتنا الى مراقبه ومداهمه
للمناطق التي تاتي منها التهديدات وبعد
اسبوع في قريه القراوه حددنا مخبا كبيرا
لاصل 11 يتضمن انواعا مختلفه من الاسلحه
كان لديهم ايضا مسدسات بالكواتم صوت
وكانوا يخططون لاستخدامها في عمليات
الاغتيال كانت هناك ايضا اسلحه مصنع
الناتو في ذلك المخبا وهذه الاسلحه لا
يمتلكها الا جيش التركي كان هناك ايضا
الكثير من القنابل اليدويه التي ينتجها
الجيش التركي
حتى في مخيم الهول تم العثور على ازياء
عسكريه للجيش التركي
صدرنا الاسلحه اثناء العمليه وكان هناك
ايضا الكثير من العبوات الناسفه وكانوا
يخططون لاستخدامها ضد سياراتنا كانت لديهم
ايضا عبوات ناسفه على جانب الطريق والسؤال
هو من اين امن داعش كل هذه المعدات
العسكريه
قد لا تنتهي تهديدات داعش في عمليه واحده
مدن راس العين وتالابيض واعزاز وعفرين
والباب وادلب تخضع لسيطره الجماعات
الارهابيه تنظيم داعش موجود في تلك
المناطق وجيش التركي لديه قوات هناك
طالما سيستمر هذا الوضع على ما عليه فلن
تنتهي تهديدات داعش طالما لم يتم قطع
العلاقات التركيه مع داعش لن تنتهي
تهديدات داعش هذا مؤكد
تقوم الدوله التركيه بتزويت داعش في راس
العين بهذه الاسلحه
ويستخدمها داعش في مناطقنا ثم يستخدمون
شاحنات لنقل هذه الاسلحه الى مناطقنا وقد
تم اكتشافه تقوم تركيا ايضا بتدريب عناصر
داعش على التكتيكات بما ان داعش قد دخلوا
حقبه جديده
لدينا خبره طويله في محاربه داعش ولكن منذ
محاوله الهروب من السجن تغيروا كثيرا لقد
غيروا الطريق التي يدورون بها هجماتهم
اعتادوا الهجوم بشكل جماعي لكنهم الان
يركزون على الاغتيالات المستهدفه كما انهم
يستخدمون العبوات الناس في اشكال صغيره
ولكن بتاثير اكبر يقومون ايضا بتوزيع
اعضائهم في مجموعات صغيره على مناطق
مختلفه التهديد الاخر الناشئ عن هذا
التنظيم الارهابي هو نظامهم الايديولوجي
يقولون ويعترفون بانهم يعتزمون اعاده
تاسيس الدوله الاسلاميه انهم على قيد
الحياه بغض النظر عن خسائرهم وذلك لان
لديهم دعما خارجيا الدوله التركيه
ترعى داعش مثل ما ترعى جيشها هذه هي
الحقيقه نحن
تشكيلا جديدا لداعش يطالب السكان المحليون
من المناطق الواقعه تحت تهديد داعش
بعمليات امنيه اضافيه طلبت منها القبائل
العربيه
والشيوخها الذين يمثلونهم تامين مناطقهم
داعش على تهديد المجتمع العربي بشخصيته
كانوا يهددونهم ويجبروهم على الانضمام
لداعش وان رفضوا يهددونهم بالقتل كان
التنظيم داعش يخطط ايضا لعمليه كبيره تبدا
من مخيم الهول وصولا الى حدود العراق
وتركيا اكتشفنا هذه التهديدات التي اراد
التنظيم داعش تنفيذها ليله راس السنه
لا يهدد داعش مجتمعاتنا فحسب بل يهدد
المنطقه باكملها لقد راينا شكل دولتهم
تحدثي عن من القي القبض عليهم ولكن فيما
يتعلق بالاعداد عدد الدواعش او على الاقل
المتهمين بالانتماء لتنظيم داعش اللذيذ
القيتم القبض عليهم
الكلاسيكو
اعتقلنا ما يقرب عن 170 عنصرا من داعش
اثناء العمليه في مخيم الهول يرجى التحقيق
معهم حاليا
واحتجزنا معظم هذه العناصر لاننا كنا
نراقب تحركاتهم كانوا مطلوبين وكانوا
يقومون بالتجنيد لداعش فيما خطط عناصر
اخرون من داعش للتحضير لهجماتهم القادمه
المناطق التي تحتلها تركيا في سوريا هي
الملاذ الامن لداعش يحاول التنظيم داعش
توزيع قواته خارج تلك المناطق من اجل
تنفيذ هجمات كبيره
يحاول داعش بشكل اساسي مد نفوذه من تلك
المناطق الى حدود العراق ومخيم الهول ويجب
ان تستمر عملياتنا لازاله هذه التهديدات
تهديدات داعش خطيره ولدينا العديد من اسرع
داعش في السجون عفرين اعزاز الباب كالابيض
راس العين هي في الاساس المناطق التي تدعم
فيها قوات داعش الدوله التركيه ترعى داعش
علنا والطالما استمر ذلك ستكون هناك
تهديدات اكبر من داعش المنطقه الهشه او
الضعيفه التي يستطيع تنظيم داعش العوده
اليها وبناء نفسه من جديد في سوريا او حتى
خارج سوريا وخاصه في سوريا من هي ما هي
هذه المنطقه يعني كاسك لا توجد شعوب سعيده
بنظام داعش كان الناس محبطين من حكم داعش
الخوف هو انه عندما تدخل داعش منطقه قد لا
يتمكن الناس من الوقوف في وجهها هناك
مناطق معينه في سوريا بها هذا الضعف يتم
تامين مناطقنا بشكل فعال ولكن هذا ليس هو
الحال بالنسبه لاجزاء اخرى في سوريا هناك
خطر من قيام داعش بتنفيذ هجمات مره اخرى
يبحث داعش عن الفرصه وقد يهاجمون المناطق
المعرضه للخطر يوفر الاحتلال التركي مساحه
لداعش لاعاده التنظيم والتجمع تم استهداف
واستشهاد عدد من رفاقنا من قبل الطائرات
التركيه المسيره هذا دعم رئيسي اخر تقدمه
تركيا للتنظيم داعش مع ابقائهم في المناطق
المحتله
بدون الدعم التركي لا يمكن للداعش ان
يستمر الهجمات التركيه على قواتنا تشتت
انتباهنا عن القتال ضد داعش تنظيم داعش
لا تتحدثون عن خلاياه وانما داخل المخيمات
مش مخيم الهول
ما عرفناه منكم بان عدد الولايات الولادات
تتزايد جدا داخل هذا المخيم
لديكم اعداد تقريبيه على الاقل حول عدد
الولادات للعائلات الداعشيه والى اي حد
هذا يعتبر خطر جديد عليكم
في الواقع هذا تهديد كبير هناك 80 ولاده
شهريه في المخيمات التي تضم عائله داعش
بعد معركه البغوث اطفال داعش الذين كانوا
في العشره من العمر هما الان في عمر
السادسه عشره من العمر
هؤلاء الاطفال لا يلعبون الالعاب التي
يلعبها الاطفال العاديون يستخدمون اي شيء
في المخيم كسلاح ويلعبون او بالاحرى
يتدربون معهم
عندما ينمو الطفل في مثل هذه الاجواء في
بعض الوقت يمكن ان يصبح العضو الرئيسي
لداعش كيف تتزايد الولاداتهم داخل هذا
المخيم نهار
الدوله الاسلاميه
ليس كل عنصر من عناصر داعش في السجن لديهم
متعاطفون من الذكور في المخيم ايضا يسمح
داعش للرجال بالزواج من اربع نساء في نفس
الوقت لقد درسنا انشطه الذكور في مخيم
الهول لقد راينا العديد من الرجال الذين
تزوجوا من اربع نساء في نفس الوقت كما
انهم يسمحون للمراهقين بالتسواج من اجل
الحفاظ على ايديولوجياتهم هذا يؤدي فعليا
الى المزيد من الولادات في المخيم
ليس كل رجل من داعش في السجن المتعاطفون
معهم في المخيمات لكن بعض المخيمات من
المفترض انه لا يوجد فيها رجال ومع هذا من
الملاحظه جدا بين عدد الولايات تتزايد
الولادات تتزايد بحسبكم وحتى بحسب
الملاحظات
هل لديكم تفسير حول ما يجري داخل هذه
المخيمات وكيف تتزايد هذه الاعداد ولادات
في مخيمات من المفترض
لا يوجد بها رجال ولا تجب بها عائلات
قام باجنبيان
يجب ان يكون قسم الاجانب في المعسكرات
عاده بدون رجال اثناء العمليه اكتشفنا
انهم اخفوا المراهقين الذكور في الانفاق
التي حفروها كانوا يفعلون ذلك حتى لا
تتمكن قوات الامن من اكتشافهم انهم
يستخدمون هؤلاء المراهقين لاغراض الانجاب
هناك لاجئون عراقيون وبعض النازحين
السوريين يذهبون خلصتا الى قسم الاجانب
ويتزوجوا من اجنبيه هم يستخدمون كل هذه
الطرق لانجاب المزيد من الاطفال
[موسيقى]